protestas como lo que hay a mi alrededor
se están repitiendo por todas colombia
en el día de hoy están convocadas por
diferentes colectivos sociales y con
motivos muy diversos sin embargo hay uno
que está uniendo a gran parte de la
sociedad colombiana y es la última
reforma tributaria del gobierno de iván
duque que pretende recaudar fondos para
paliar las consecuencias de la crisis de
la pandemia en las rentas más bajas sin
embargo esto ha sido visto por las
clases medias y asalariadas como una
forma de que estos subsidios recaigan
sobre sus hombros y no sobre los de las
clases más altas
la popularidad de iván duque llega en
este momento en uno de sus peores
momentos con el 30 por ciento de
popularidad cifra similar a la de
noviembre de 2019 cuando se vivieron las
marchas más multitudinarias en colombia
en décadas sin embargo la situación
actualmente es incluso más grave con un
15 por ciento de desempleo pero también
con un aumento de la desigualdad y una
fatiga pandémica a causa de las
restricciones y es que la pandemia en
colombia está en uno de sus peores
momentos con más de 400 muertos diarios
en la última semana pero también con las
unidades de cuidados intensivos de las
principales ciudades por encima del 90
por ciento y también por el ritmo de
vacunación lento que está llevando el
país